salez les amis bienvenue dans steam
fomule âge j'avais un problème nous
trouverons la solution
voici les liens il est comme qui dirait
une love de sabrina
malheureusement il est beaucoup trop
introverti objectifs verts de lilian un
vrai tombeur
à l'est du camp
les amis bienvenue dans notre qg c'est
ici que lilian on va devenir une toute
autre personne quand on regarde ligne en
une chose interpelle les viandes n'a
aucun style ouais je j'entends par
contre julien villion on s'occupe de
tout j'efface occupe et auront encore
plus fashion fashion de chez fashions
let's go
m
bienvenue lilian demanderaient s'il
regarde ça qu'est ce que tu en penses
sans jette un max
j'ai concocté ce qui se fait de mieux en
matière de style parce que excuse moi
mais vestimentairement parlant ressemble
plus à un pasteur qu'autre chose a bien
verrouillé mec votre plan pour m'aider
c'est de nous rabaisser en fait les des
relaxes mais qu une fois qu on t'aura
relooké tu seras plus s'il est que le
style bien envoyé des fcm rassuré c'est
cette promesse
vous
bien sûr
j'ai l'impression que le crapaud c'est
transformer en prince charmant
sarlat c'est bien pour vous ça l'iran a
raison le style ne suffit pas il lui
manque encore une chose pour pouvoir
atteindre sabrina les scores l'apparence
est réglé lilian et plus frais que
ferait maintenant dustin va s'occuper
d'améliorer un nouvel aspect je sens que
ça va ce plh est alors les lions
regagner un peu de confiance en toi je
te propose fort logiquement d'un ben je
sais pas si j'avais la solution je n'ai
pas besoin de vous je pensais de faire
un battle de danse pas la solution mais
je sais que c'est pas ça la solution par
tous ces parcs
b
tous
comme tout c'est la dernière étape avant
dasson sabrina
ouais
qui fait clairement honneur à sa tenue
et
mission accomplie les amis le travail de
la team fosse où s'arrête ici lilian a
maintenant tout ce qu'il faut pour
pouvoir conquérir sabrina j'ai
l'impression qu'il a toujours envie de
danser à les mecs c'est parce que c'est
fini pour nous on se retrouve la semaine
prochaine pour aider régis qui a du mal
à trouver un job
régis avec un tel nom portier tu
m'étonne qu'on laisse toujours à la
porte alors les petit gringalet
j'ai l'impression qu'on à enjoy et un
mac cet épisode dans ce cas je te
propose de t'abonner hier pour un max de
fun pour un max de terry pour un max de
cool un max de cool sasy pa yeah yeah